I think it's the breath of of
applications and solutions uh within you
know with the same framework of solution
that we have we've been working with so
many clients in
different uh markets uh different
geographies uh you know at the end of
the day it's all around people so that's
definitely the most enjoyable part for
me is the interaction with people but
then when you see the result when you
see how they apply our technology that
you know was conceived here by a
relatively small team uh and you know
we're we're we're helping to change the
world welcome to 20-minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord venture
J Ventures Riverside FM Fusion VC
Birthright Excel J impact leap Google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with
[Music]
ctec Assaf suic welcome to a 20 leaders
thank you so much for joining me I'm
really um excited to be talking to you
about um your journey the Journey of
iguazio um acquisition to McKenzie the
whole world of AI application building
and deployment within Enterprises and
large organizations obviously we're
we're all drawn to what's been happening
this past year with the AR Revolution it
hasn't passed any organization's mind
and I've been particularly curious about
how Enterprises um in part are adopting
these sorts of Technologies and looking
at it h so I'm I'm really excited to
look to go back all the way to 2015 and
before that even as to how you've been
looking at data the data Science World
in the context of organization so again
Asaf thank you so much for being here
tell me a little bit about your
background because before iguazio you've
actually had quite a bit of background
and experience in the tax sector with
some phenomenal companies so so share
with me a little bit about your journey
and what led to your understandings sure
Michael first I'm really happy to be
here and I'm glad uh we're talking um so
if we go back uh in fact uh back in the
80s that's when I started my journey and
um actually my first experience with
computer was pretty bad I was actually
even programming as a kid with uh IBM
Punch Cards I had the opportunity to do
that and it wasn't that a great of
experience but following that I had uh
you know my ti99 that changed the the
the experience but then uh already in my
second year in the technium I had my
first AI course that was by far the best
experience through the whole four years
in the technium um and I knew um this is
going to be big you know AI had it uh
fashion cycles that were you know I
think we're now into the sixth wave of
AI but AI has always been there but for
sure uh chatu changed everything uh and
made it accessible to so many people and
you know it's not surprising that the
economist picked generative AI as their
Award of the
year so um um going back um so u in
terms of um my personal career um as
many people in the tech sector on the
business side uh they start their career
on the R&D side so I was actually uh a
software developer uh leading teams um
for the first uh eight nine years of my
career um and then um switched to the
dark side of business uh uh product uh
product marketing um uh Partnerships u u
business devel velopment marketing uh
this has been uh the last uh I would say
23 years after my MBA in IMD business
school in Switzerland that uh was an
amazing International experience um and
since then it's been um an amazing ride
uh first with uh voler a company that
was already in the HBC high performance
Computing and financial services space
where
um we that we took public in NASDAQ back
in 2007 later got acquired by melanox
that is now part of Nvidia that actually
started our um all our relationships
within
Nvidia um before and after the
acquisition of melanox by
Nvidia um and um in between you know um
we started uh just before starting uh
iguazio I was uh for a couple years at a
company called compass that uh we were
in the Silicon photonic space um where
physics and uh electronics and software
meet each other very very interesting
experience there but then in um
2014 hooked up with my friends at from
voler yon seev yon kiv and R uh Nissan
messing and um we
saw uh initially it was more around
people trying to harness data but very
quickly we realize that the top
application that are trying to combine
historical online data real-time data
into insights and actions and
predictions where um the the toughest
applications were related to data
science and the gap between that PC that
you have in Ai and then taking it to the
business upon this we actually uh
founded iguazio and uh this is where we
are
today love it so first of all
fascinating background and I can only
imagine the the breath of experience
that you get from from from going from
your experience in Academia to the real
world top leading software engineering
teams and being a part of these um kind
of groundbreaking organizations that
especially especially in the Israeli
tick ecosystem but but more but in
general you know globally and really
being at that always at that Cutting
Edge and seeing the problems as they
arise if you if you want to double down
on that Gap that you've observed in the
context of going from P's leveraging you
know this data ingestion all the way to
the Insight formation leveraging machine
learning capabilities what what were
those main gaps of going from POC to
productionizing 2015 what did you see
sort of come up again and again and and
it was the was also what when that
happened was there a distinction between
sort of the Enterprises and smaller
companies or was it more generally a
paino that was true for
everybody so this is where I
differentiate between the tech Giants
actually I I always use the term that
you know uh AI is a luxury of the tech
Giants they've been using it you know
they've been
know using our data for years and using
AI Technologies uh extracting and
monetizing it in in an amazing way right
but it was you know a luxury of you know
the the Googles of the world the
Facebooks of the world um but it wasn't
really propagating into you know the
largest banks the largest uh um you know
industrial companies and everybody
everybody I mean already back in 2015 we
playing with AI with AI they were uh you
know actually um a few couple months ago
I met with um a CIO of a company that
said um that she had more pilots in AI
than the pilots the number of pilots in
American Airlines I mean say I mean she
had pilot sickness because they were
doing pilots and pilot and those Pilots
were proving the business value of a
particular technology and AI but you
check a year later a couple of year
later that project died on its way to
production there is a huge gap and in
fact generative AI increases that Gap
because with generative AI the creating
a demo or or starting to use something
basic is very easy I mean the Gap I mean
the the the ability to deliver something
like a demo there is is relatively easy
taking it to production generative is
actually harder than before because you
know we mentioned in video because of
the usage of gpus which is non-trivial
to say the least and and that Gap is
increasing so you were asking me about
particular reasons and I I think I can
name several first with this whole thing
that AI was considered some sort of
magic so that group of data scientists
that were you know typically phds that
did lots of research and in Academia uh
they continue to do this kind of
research within those Enterprises and
for the first few years most Enterprises
were happy with the fact that they're
doing research that they're
experimenting what will be the future of
their field with AI but then the the the
fact that we're considered as a silo a
technology Silo and were not integrated
as part of the general software
development life cycle that was a a a
problem that I'm sure you're familiar
with cicd all these technologies that we
have now for for decades that are
continuously allowing organizations to
deploy applications into in the
day-to-day cicd was not applied in the
space of AI in machine learning because
you have more Dimensions software cicd
it's relatively easy I mean it's
one-dimensional source code objects you
know binaries versions that's it more or
less but when it comes to machine
learning suddenly you have the software
you have the models that are integrated
within the software and usually are have
a life of its own of their own because
they're uh progressing in a different
pace than the actual software around
them and then you need to also connect
it to their data sets the original data
set that was used to train that model
and with the whole world of G governance
and you know regulation that is coming
upon us or already started with AI you
need that you need that to be super
governed and and people were not doing
that it was a little bit more
complicated um and they didn't know how
to do that that's one of the areas that
today we always zoom in when we work
with large Enterprises see how you can
actually you have your own cicd already
we work we will work with you Mr
customer on how to actually expand your
cicd tools today to also be applied to
machine learning and AI so that's one
area um another area is the uh ability I
mean people thought that okay just by
using my um data sources you know my
data warehouse my um you know my
operational systems I can actually
integrate all of that and uh and build
an application it's very different when
you actually run it in your development
lab where your data scientists have all
the time in the world to create and and
you know massage the data into these
large tables and you know csvs files
whatever uh they're using uh and based
on that uh run the the you know train
the model run the model um and then when
you look at it in the real world
suddenly you have some of the data that
is sitting in very old uh data
warehouses that are very slow and then
other sources of data very fast where
you have streaming data coming from
let's say credit card
transactions and people you know in
order to move it to production they
eventually needed to rewrite their
application so what we're doing with our
clients we're actually showing them that
there are ways to actually build those
applications once and this is called you
know feature engineering that the
feature engineering can be done once uh
and that will be applied both for the
lab work and the day-to-day work this is
basically using a whole field I mean of
course we won't be able to get into that
today with offline and online feature
stores that's also uh a key part of of
uh the work we're doing with with our
clients so um these are two out of you
know several big problem that people
have you know around the data around
their internal processes it's not just
technology we always you know when we
start engagement with with a client it's
it's this triangle of Technology
processes and people and it always it
keeps moving all the time and we work
with them now part of McKenzie uh you
know we cover all
three how has the conversation changed
or evolved over the last nine years and
then I'd love to get into McKenzie and
the the integration
there yeah it's been it's been it's been
uh very interesting to see the evolution
over the years and as I said before you
know people were quite happy with the
fact that they have a research team that
shows uh what will be the future but
that patience of the business side has
actually over time uh got uh you know uh
smaller and smaller and people wanted to
see results and over time we saw that
actually leaders in data science heads
of data science groups that felt okay we
need to show the value in the business
not just to show a beautiful model that
works great in the lab and uh we
actually uh started working with those
leaders within the technology sector of
you know data science group that had
that business affiliation to show the
value and eventually we saw new roles we
saw um the position of ml engineer we
saw the position of mlops engineer we
saw the term mlops evolving it didn't
exist in
2015 uh so um it's it's it's it's it's
great to see such a you know this
trajectory of a new technology that
evolves with new positions and let's not
forget to talk about the fact that
Iguazu keeps hiring and we've been
growing the team um so um you know it's
um
we will get to that too um and uh you
were asking about the perspective of
McKenzie how it all fits yeah how did it
happen how did that fit and and how is
this now augmenting what UI was
doing so we actually started with a
partnership with McKenzie um um you know
uh friendship that turned into
marriage um we um McKenzie uh not a lot
of people especially in the Israeli uh
um Market are aware of the fact that
McKenzie has thousands thousands of data
scientists data Engineers mckenzi may be
one of the largest AI companies uh
McKenzie acquired in 2015 a company
called Quantum black that that core team
has actually evolved into the quantum
black operation Within mckin that
delivers AI projects which are the heart
of these large transformation project
that mckeny does for you know the best
Enterprises in the world if if you think
about it the term transformation um in
2023 there is always AI that actually
sits somewhere in this big machine that
actually is applied on a uh on a on a
client that is actually moving through
this transformation the transformation
includes uh the ability to actually have
within their organization uh the ability
to adopt AI Technologies to actually uh
deliver Concepts that come from the
business into applications that are
applied whether it's in as I said in
manufacturing Banks um you know
basically every every vertical Market
that that you can think of there's
always um opportunities with AI
applications and U you know the
acquisition happened in
January um
2023 a couple of months after uh chap
GPT created this awareness around Ai and
the the most discussed topic McKinsey
had with its clients in 2023 was AI by
far so the timing
uh is amazing and um as you can imagine
we're we're spending our time uh with
with you know the the largest
Enterprises in the world or um the best
Enterprises in the world that are trying
to adopt AI in a better way uh some of
them are somewhere in their Journey uh
you know most companies are doing some
something already today but also most of
them are very inefficient on how they're
doing that they're seeing the
potential um and it became a top topic
for CEOs that you know eventually uh are
propagating it down within the
organization so I can say we're super
busy what's been the most enjoyable part
for you in this whole process I can see
how clearly passionate you are about
this topic and about the space and
everything that you've been going
through also today but what's been
really the most enjoyable part for you
you as you're reflecting on this last
decade and looking into the next
one I think it's the breath of of
applications and solutions uh within you
know with the same framework of solution
that we have we've been working with so
many clients in
different uh markets uh different
geographies uh you know at the end of
the day it's all around people so that's
definitely the most enjoyable part for
me is the interaction with people but
then when you see the result when you
see how they apply our technology that
you know was conceived here by a
relatively small team uh and you know
we're we we're helping to change the
world well I think that it's a it's a
unique experience going back all the way
to this start of your journey in the 80s
and and then teon and doing you know
studying the space but then fting the
six waves I guess as you're talking and
and then being at The Cutting Edge of
the latest one uh in you know triggered
perhaps by CH GPT last November but but
really being there with you know the
best of the best like McKenzie over in
January and getting and now working with
you know the most amazing companies and
and seeing the adoption and the
adaptations so I think that's extremely
exciting and ASA I really want to thank
you for spending these 20 minutes with
me and sharing your journey
wishing you the very best of luck with
everything that you'll do either with
iguazio or anything else and uh and I
can't wait for all of us to see what
will happen in this new wave and and
these exciting times and um very excited
to be sharing the story of of your own
Journey inazu as
well wonderful thank you very much and
as as I said uh you know
um within 2023 that wasn't that easy for
the tech sector in general uh we kept on
hiring and we keep on hiring and would'
love um to see people join the team here
again it became it was an amazing
experience before the acquisition after
the acquisition it's even
better wonderful thank you so much
really appreciate your time and your
energy thank you thank you thank you
Michael
byebye